hi leute ich sitze hier zusammen mit
sturm waffe und marcel margaux und wir
werden heute verdammt noch mal reagieren
man ganz kurz bevor das video losgeht
aus irgendeinem grund hat youtube sich
entschieden ihr merkt schon meine stimme
ist schon einfach sagen ähnlich wie ich
meine youtube videos einfach komplett
niemandem anzuzeigen deshalb gibt es
hier am sonntag notiert
aber ich würde euch wirklich bitten wenn
ihr meine videos mit und wollte dass ich
nicht in der irrelevanz versinke bitte
dann schreibt einen kommentar lassen
leichter und wir zeigen im algorithmus
wir die kranken menschen sind hier mit
absolut gesagt wir gucken uns heute eine
youtube kacke von niemand geringeren als
dollar an ich glaube wir uns vor einer
ewigkeit sebastian ich mal doch das buch
der bräune angeschaut wie gucken heute
komme und der tomaten automat von dem
youtube katyn gott galilei als 100.000
abonnenten special mittlerweile hat der
400.000 tut mir jetzt das video an wir
versuchen nicht zu lachen was passiert
wenn jemand lacht ich für so ein 100.000
rausstellt alter libanese vielleicht
passiert was wenn jemand lag deshalb
gleich glücklichen 2 3 und los geht's
[Musik]
ist schon für mich feier war da bin ich
was als ob du in den bio drin müsst
alter das licht und der wald braucht
jetzt so alten die sebastian damals
waren sie sich sieht auch sebastian ich
finde rechner kann nicht jeder sieht
auch volk halten ist das her ich weiß es
nicht die geilheit hauptsache ich will
einfach hier nur so ein bisschen bürger
in den kämpfen immer wieder von cherry
das hast du bis dahin gesehen und
gewusst dass dem video ist willst du sie
höre habe ich nicht ich würde wirklich
ok weiter geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ihr seid unglaublich
ich wusste dass bei grad da private mal
bin ich gerade dom und hab das schon mal
gesehen habe ich etwas kommentiert nein
sebastian kommentiert machst du da bist
alter mann
du hast nichts anderes zu tun als zu
essen super dann hatten die nur noch ein
kleiner doppelkopf frei denn die an der
rezeption schon sagt es ist ein kleiner
mag ich mir gar nicht ausmalen was das
für ein paar dann auf dem weg rennt weg
vater stand dieser automat voll mit
[Musik]
ketten immer so diese einfachen sachen
wenn er so aufwendig so ein wort drin
ist und damit auch den automaten mit dem
ich will einmal persönlich kennenlernen
mit dem kannst du glauben gericht guten
abend vergeben der die scheiße schnell
wäre sehr muss hier komplett absolute
absolute helfen aber auch und witzig
sind einfach so dank martin die leute
ändert die am umzug mitgehen hast du es
ja so sind und er kommt zu uns und
spendet so sein content ein verschwendet
ein für die leute die es spendet
einschießen community care gibt leuten 1
haas hier ist was los ist denn schon
wieder befreit
wir erzählen sie sehe sich nur marken
sind wahrscheinlich lassen wir wirklich
in deutschland band oder wir probieren
jetzt mal kurz überhaupt keine miene zu
verziehen der als erstes fazit das thema
ist tatsächlich sehr klein aber nicht so
klein ist nach einer weile hat jeder
wenn die schlafposition gefunden würde
ich ganz breit gemacht hat in dem bett
da hat die kleine sich ganz so breit
gemacht so verschlafen
[Gelächter]
mit tampa schloss mit einem abschlag zu
helfen warum ich hab hunger schlafen
wir sind ihr modells in die kleine
schrift die strafe und lässt sich jetzt
auch wieder zu machen
der vollstrecker war respektvoll zu
einem polizisten bis auf endlich darf
ich nach die füße müssen
ich will mich erinnern ich war also
wieder alle 30 wirkungslos
es macht mich krank wirst du sehen noch
dauern wie überlebt dieser mensch da ist
wenn er das schneiden muss also nicht
richtig gewundert wenn
ob dsl modem legt sich wieder auf ihren
haken und vor allem engel schwanz doch
kaum leben sie wie krähen liegt also ich
muss sagen einem attraktivität mit dem
kollegen ja und jetzt also galilei ist
ein so großartiges video wieder
ich habe mich echt gefreut mich am
anfang selbst zu sehen weil wir euch
vielleicht auch erinnert habe ich ja vor
einiger zeit schon mal reaktionen auf
youtube kaffee gemacht schreibt gerne
eure kommentare
dennoch meine schrift wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder dabei sein muss habe
mir echt spaß hat bei jedem fall die
kommentare
egal was okay war